Assistance requested
by army and municipal police!
Someone's attacking an army convoy!
They've stolen an IFV and are now fleeing
towards the capital on the Aqua Line!
The royal family has declared martial law!
-We're to obey Gen. Bern's instructions!
-What's this?
Is this a revolution?
Everyone, get there ASAP!
-Mario! Take command on scene!
-Roger!
Brandon, you're our liaison
with the local cops!
-Roger!
-Boris!
Could you handle the army?
Please oversee our unit placement!
-Wait, you want me to do it?
-Yes, you!
All right, fine.
-Keith.
-What?
There's an emergency.
I'd like your assistance.
You flies are getting on my nerves!
This looks like trouble.
Lily! We're gonna get behind it!
-Can you get ahead of or next to it?
-Uh...
Cut through the park!
Rodger Dodger!
W-Wait, Lily! Don't--
I didn't mean it literally!
Use the road! The road!
Target acquired!
Lily!
Here we come!
-Lily! It's firing at us!
-Sorry! Falling back!
Lily!
We can't get near it with this car!
You get ahead of it!
Where is he? Come on out!
Show yourself, you monster!
Die!
I'll crush you all!
This guy is nuts.
I have no idea what his objective is!
We're not letting him get away!
Julian, I hate to interrupt
while you're having fun,
but it's time to lose them.
Hey, Mario!
Watch the sensors!
A smoke screen and an APS?
This isn't an ordinary IFV?
It probably contains
carbon fiber particles.
Radar waves are being jammed.
Unable to monitor situation.
-Anything on thermal?
-Not a thing.
Seal off all areas immediately.
Just get that thing contained.
This is Alpha!
Eric! Where'd the IFV go?
Requesting instructions!